this is the agency that is going to
teach the next generation how to do the
new form of creative it's cool
[Music]
I move with the weight of the world on
my leg can I just read but it's done
only you need a person to fight me -
Carlo me
everybody got Drive to the car Roger you
got a brought on good afternoon
a couple weeks ago or a month ago I
thought it would be a good idea to get a
lot of the creative leaders in the
company together but what I want to
accomplish here through the four or five
hours of discussion is actually just to
get us collectively hearing the
discussion I want to basically have
conversations of things that I'm seeing
a lot a lot of what I think 2017 has
been about at vaynermedia was somewhere
around September in October of last year
it just became obvious to me the
organization had become too far away
from what I thought needed to be done in
output of work in culture in many
different facets and I think
collectively a series of events whether
it's the reorg or different things or
when I spoke at the end of the year last
year that made it a very short
end-of-the-year talk about we're going
to be the best Facebook commercial that
is that whole thing a lot of my energy
is in that direction I want to continue
it to be in that direction so to this
collective today is not to talk about
structure or job titles or
responsibilities we talk about the I
want to talk about the work I want to
spend the entire time here talking about
the work what what does the work look
like to you and I really want people to
participate you know we'll get into jams
of like good or interesting or
opportunities or other things you've
seen but ultimately what I want to do is
have the discussion be the output of
today and then I'll take it back to the
lab and decide if there's things that I
want to do or don't do but I think it's
going to be very healthy for a lot of
people to hear other people's points of
view or thoughts or dreams or
aspirations of what we do here and I
really want to set the tone on a couple
of the pillars and we're where we're
going to go so why don't we go around it
and say hello let's go counterclockwise
because I think that's funny Juliet
because you're looking in your bag why
don't you start
we'll burn to the cashier chasing the
can't even turned on me but it's hard to
be man when you big homie to that been
lonely too much time with this guy had
about eight days in the month is about
any month I want to make sure that we
walk around with the audacity that we
should have not worrying about being
treated like the below-the-line
afterthought oh we set the tone and I
don't care and I love now that's easy
for me because I'm playing the long game
right but I'd like to empower and please
figure out what you need to not care as
well when I feel those vibes I
especially from another agency I laugh
at it yet understand once the television
commercial marketplace collapses the
entire above the line traditional agency
world goes through massive disruption no
different that bookstores and limousine
services had to when their markets
collapsed because of innovation and so
this is a very important time for us
because here's why we have to at all
cost
become the organization that is most
known for making the modern-day mobile
commercial whether that is in Facebook
where I've been sending a lot of the
energy or for a lot of brands here that
are targeting 30 and under I've become
increasingly fascinated with the
interstitial snapchat ad that allows you
to swipe up and then watch three four
five six minute video and if you look at
the macro data of the depth of
consumption in that platform on
long-form video once swiped up it's
scary so to me I'd like to put it in the
in the in the bucket of long-form mobile
video you know I think one thing that
people are not spending enough time on
is everybody's lazy right everybody's
lazy everybody lazily reads headlines
that and thinks and you've been everyone
of you have been in a meeting in the
last six months when talking about video
for the mobile device people think it
needs to be short that it needs to be 15
or 30 seconds right first of all this
whole notion of 15 30 and 60 is
ludicrous it is completely format
based on how television eventually
formed itself and the thought that we
should every be thinking about that in
this new environment is ludicrous and I
want to make sure we know that number to
get yourself educated get to the
analytics team go read like long-form
video works on mobile devices and I want
you to push back when you're in a room
and they go well that has to be a
10-second video or 15-second video like
two three four or five minute videos
work they just have to be good today
we're in a weird little limbo that I
would say we're 20% all the way through
right and tomorrow we're going to be on
the right side of this equation and so I
just think the advertising world that we
all grew up with or we're passionate
about is is unbelievably on its last
breath and I'll tell you why it doesn't
just start and end with traditional I
would tell you that I believe that
almost the far majority of a digital
advertising is straight garbage so I
look at print and outdoors modern
version as a facebook picture I love the
idea we would we want to like we want an
opportunity with if we won the social
AOR if we did if we got it now we're
taking over the first three months two
months if our pictures on there are with
purpose to get to creative insights both
quantum qua I love the idea that our
video work starts at month three because
we didn't work to get us insights not
just relied on our insights team or a
brief and the way we interpret it we
actually used quantum reason my content
works so well as I respond to the
content and then make more content and
so it's an inexpensive way for us not to
waste the clients money for the first
two months you put on a bunch of stuff
you see what actually works that's then
along with the insights team the pillars
and when we create the four videos
it's just yeah buddy we are a winning
digital creative shop this is about
winning it all this is not a
conversation like please nobody leave
here with like woe is me you know bad it
is out there like like we're winning
it's just we're not going to win the
game that's coming and that's my
responsibility right that's ultimately
my responsibility so that's what I'm
really focused on here like we're
winning because guess what
every agency only cares about the
subjective call of this and not
respecting the context of the platforms
and working off of the digital asset
interpretation of the 30-second spot and
mailing it in and just doing it for
programmatic media then nobody sees at
all there's no shop that is devoted to
being a disproportionately talented
video creative shops in a facebook
environment committed that's what that's
what I want us to be this is the agency
that is going to teach the next
generation how to do the new form of
creative it's cool I like that my
product really so much beyond my mind
[ __ ] out no no leads
we're like a spore our feet
[Music]
so much crowd you want to be successful
you google things you google things like
how to make a facebook video go viral
with the first three seconds or what's
good in the first five seconds like Get
Smart
the first article ever written about me
in my career was in The star-ledger in
New Jersey New Jersey State paper and it
was called titled great expectations and
it was and it was written about this 25
year old kid who launched a website and
has now built one of the biggest liquor
stores in the country right here in
Springfield New Jersey and there's a
very long quote for me in the article
probably Google this and [ __ ] man I
can't believe how fun this is about the
sex in it
they interview me and they go what's the
secret of Wine Library I go one of the
three most successful wholesalers these
are people you buy your wine from who's
the legendary guy who's the smart guy of
the three you know one of them was
family inherited the other one
supposedly lucky ish but I don't believe
in that but this was the smart one this
was the guy who really was thoughtful
and was smart in it my quote is one of
them sat down with me and dinner the
first year I started running Wine
Library I started making some changes
and he sat me down he asked me for
dinner and this was supposed to be a big
deal it was an honor for me to have this
dinner with this legendary wholesaler
and halfway through the dinner he says
to me Cherie running a successful wine
shop takes three things price selection
and service and what you young man have
to figure out this year is which two of
those three you're going to focus on to
build a successful business this is me
telling the story and then I say and in
that moment as a 22 year old kid I said
in my head this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm going to do three out of three
the brand since it's out and they go
we've got a tough budget year it could
be a tough year we have no money and
they said they had two million dollars
and it seemed like a fortune we are
absolutely in a [ __ ] bubble my friends
I'm just going to remind you there's two
young women there in Savannah and
they're going to [ __ ] kill you you
know why they can do a lot of [ __ ] with
and we don't think we can please help me
change that culture nearest one about
that let me just send it to me we're all
on the same page now
like meaning like makes the [ __ ]
videos that we want to make be smart
work with each other it's great to get
that getting us all grounded in what of
allowing for a platform which people
could call that enabled you to like
community in on that uh-huh big right
yeah doing the work in real time in
front of everybody which is well that's
with real-world examples like I think
that was the most powerful stuff there
that I got is like literally taking
exactly examples of going well here I
tweaked that it's weak that that's
[ __ ] who cares and then just the
dialogue that surrounds it I think that
at least for me specific examples ago
got it okay now I can extrapolate that
and get to take that knowledge of
different direction people don't read
that and it's not your fault I'm not
getting it it's the i-5 draft more and
different and intriguing ways to
articulate it yeah and this was you know
maybe this was the one that got you know
you chip away
you didn't probably love it I think so
too I mean I think look just getting
everybody aligned on things in a moment
in time so all the different fractions
can't speak to the way it used to be the
way it's going to be the way they
interpreted that was pretty crystal
clear honestly if I just leave with
everybody making videos in those six
formats or genres like to the best of
their [ __ ] ability that would be a
game changer for us it will work
I pray down
[Music]
[Music]